I think you have alluded to bone broth before, but is that okay for cancer patients?
So bone broth is typically used to help heal the gut. Why does bone broth work to heal the gut?
What's that? Is there something magic in bone broth? No, what's in bone broth? You know, when you take
beef bones or chicken bones, you put them in water and you cook them for three days.
You're basically drawing a lot of nutrients out of the bone. When you're done making bone broth,
you could basically eat the bone because it's just soft. Typically, when you're trying to
heal the gut, you can eat the bones except maybe a big beef bone, but definitely chicken bone
when you make chicken bone broth, you could eat the bones and it would be good for you.
But the reason why bone broth is so good to help heal leaky gut is because you're
drawing so much glutamate out of the bones. So the amount of glutamate in bone broth is super high.
That's why it's so good to help heal the gut because glutamate helps cell turnover,
helps cells reproduce, really stimulates reproduction of epithelial cells.
And that's the lining of the gutter epithelial cells. Well, if you have cancer, you don't want to
be turning on growth factors for epithelial cells. So I wouldn't use bone broth for a person that
has cancer. Well, let's say my cancer is in remission, I'm doing really well. Could you use
bone broth for a short period of time to help heal the gut? Yes, I would say yes, you can.
But for a short period of time, maybe a week, and then go back to other things. There's a lot of
other things other than elglutamine that you could use to help heal the gut. So it's not like your
gut's not going to heal if you don't take elglutamine or bone broth with high concentrations about
glutamates. It's not necessary. So I would tend to just stay away from it.